tell it to an Asian parents after their
son has just gone through four years of
university to get a master's degree and
then get a job at the BBC they're gonna
quit that to talk about anomie titties I
would be angry hello and welcome to
another episode of trash tastes I am
your host for today gig United Kingdom
Arizona and with me today are my usual
co-hosts the 93 percent and the hentai
boy that's me and today we also have our
very first guest with us today I
introduce yourself I'm Chris and I'm
like what's your channel name abroad in
Japan it's a clever pun because my
surname is broad took me a long time to
figure out actually cuz when I heard
that you were like oh yeah I'm Chris
polish I just [ __ ] go no no I'm just
like holy [ __ ] that's genius wait a
minute abroad I got I didn't realize
that's right yeah cuz when you said that
right like you were like oh my name is
Chris broad I didn't say my name is
Chris but like because I cuz you know I
heard like the abroad in Japan thing and
I was like oh it's probably a pawn but
I'm like it's too good to be a pawn yeah
good it's that good yeah yeah I was like
Chris Broadcom be a real name how long
did it take you to come up with that was
it just like my first yeah I've always
hated the name broad crisp just sounds
like a second name that's easy to
pronounce broad broad you can't [ __ ] it
up can you but when I came to Japan I
thought wait a minute I can actually use
my name for once in a pun that's clever
oh my god I didn't tell me my name was
chris broad until three years into doing
you cheap clever I think that's three
years I think that's more effort than
either of us put into like our username
combined the anime man how did you come
up with that name Joey man who likes
Adam story that's an interesting point
actually cuz you've kind of like
solidified yourself
we [ __ ] myself in that ass yeah I
can't do anything else now at least
abroad in Japan right like it was gonna
be you know that's kind of the same boat
right we're like do you feel like you
could make big branch out with that name
like that broad in Taiwan just a second
channel holding Kazakhstan coming soon
before we answer I do wanna explain what
kind of client what kind of content you
what are we getting ahead of ourselves
just trying to explain what kind of
content you do I feel like if anyone
I've watched a video about like life in
Japan or an experience yeah odds are
they've come across your channel I hope
so I mean you are technically the
biggest J blogger right now right yeah
yeah yeah in terms of sub size I'm gonna
be next one on this one but I mean when
I go home yeah cuz whenever I like
whenever I was watching videos about
Japan you would be the name that would
always pop up yeah and this was like
going back years ago we'll get back I
will get back to that in a bit but for
now trying to open our beverages well
I'm just eyeing this up for ages I'm
like and we just opened so like I think
a good topic for today pineapple strong
zero I didn't know Kieran had like a
brand of strong zero it's called Kirin
the strong the strong this dog so it
must be better than strong zero hearings
prime so if you if any of you ever come
to Japan and there's one beverage you
should try out if you do drink beverages
alcoholically then strong zero this is
life strong this is like what we call
the gaijin Killa is what you guys called
it right the guy it's colloquially the
gaijin killer because it tastes like
juice but then you realize it's just as
strong as like a wine yeah so you just
get but like it like percentage-wise is
as strong as a wine I don't know why it
[ __ ] me up way hard about any wine I've
ever had carbonated yeah I think I
blacked out every time
when songs errors involved end up no me
like not remembering drugs are hangovers
easily the worst I reckon the last time
we drank strong tears
wow I don't remember off that night and
then I I woke up with like the most
searing headache I was like yes horrible
you guys remember your first drum zero
experience no I blacked out I was a
teacher up in North Japan we had like an
end of year party every year and that
was like the one drink everyone drank
and I woke up on a beach at 5:00 a.m.
like face down six cans of six cans
those formidable one is like yeah
you feel it too is like whoa oh god no
and after that it's blackout fate how
did you take you can I call you in my I
think it was like the very first time I
think it was like three or four yeah for
summary and I cannot me handle my
alcohol pretty wide right how much you
think you can hold out hole yeah after
three strong zeros it's like inhumane
territory no one can handle because
we're like three three Brits and an
Aussie we're very very used to drinking
but for some and here's the thing every
time we every time I see someone you try
strong zero especially if they're from
the UK they're like this is this nine
percent
this isn't gonna [ __ ] me up please I'm
gonna have like two cans and they're
like wasted already and then third can
is like I'm blackout I cannot remember
this night and I don't know what it is
about this particular drink
just maybe soju yeah it's the greatest
prank you can put on your friends they
can bring to Japan it's fine it's crazy
the businessmen just drink them at like
I see it I see MIT like I think 1 p.m.
sometimes just having one eye sight the
convenient yeah damn p.m. it's time to
drink yeah seriously they're not playing
around here ok
now they're gonna optimize all the free
time they have you know what I mean
so I guess a good topic to talk about
today is basically uh just I guess our
origin stories of YouTube and just our
thoughts on YouTube isn't in general
because rule three youtubers normally we
just have anime youtubers on but now we
have like someone else who does
something a bit different we thought
that the first official cares guest of
this anime podcast is someone who has
Satoshi Kon at like in person true I'm
in the Church of like anime it's three
massive anime youtubers it's like commit
a crime just by being here it's a sacred
holy ground no it's it's really weird
why cuz you've watched Satoshi Kon which
is more like cultured than a lot of
anime fans like who are very much into
anime one of the press has a neon so
yeah any stir she taunts i guess i know
i'm tara because one of the priests need
to rebrand this podcast the priests of
animals of animal that's perfect right
so like hopefully by the end of it we
can hopefully like try and convince
Chris to like maybe give you know a few
of our recommendations ago and then
Chris can hopefully pursue Connor and
everybody who's watching and all
listening that doesn't know anything
about Satoshi Kon watch the toaster I
agree that's that's a good challenge you
drop that sauce Chris I'm open-minded i
anime i watch is good i cyst i never
really go into as a kid really part from
Pokemon or I mean I watched Digimon as
we talked about Jo and just that put me
off isn't the most respected anime
that's got a die-hard fan base I thought
that no no but I know I think I made a
joke about it and there's like a new
season people called pierced yeah I said
I'm a Washington cuz it's like it's like
a lot of people's childhood right
because I grew up on Digimon so I mean I
wouldn't say I'm a die-hard fan but I
definitely definitely enjoyed it as the
kids I played the game I don't know
which ones I did I live like that
they're like Smash Bros knock off that
was pretty fun I think it was a smash
yeah digimon Rumble arena was cold they
made like three of them aware that the
only thing I'm aware of now is the thing
stuck in my English at least like brah
brah the English one's a good one what
can I say listen the Japanese opening
it's like the like the jet the it's like
a you probably heard it's like that you
can
oh that's the song a hair karaoke yes
did you do much do they pull the
Dragonball Z right we're like Dragon
Ball Z Japanese opening was like actual
pulp the songs that English one was just
dragon dragon dragon
well that was high but that was high I
just love how it's like alright we gotta
show you what Dragon Ball Z in the song
bro that's like big brain mode though is
come get me do you not remember this at
all
gyro the English Dragon Ball thing no I
think that's like they forgot that it's
so epic so it's like iconic but how did
yeah I think the one piece rap is like
blocked out openings to me the one I see
I had the I had the pleasure of not
going to play it you had the that's like
question to you then Chris because a lot
of obviously in our circles a lot of
people we know came to Japan or moved to
Japan like based on somewhat based on
their love for anime and that's us
included so like what did you choose to
move to Japan if anime wasn't like a big
reason or any reason
yeah that's asked a lot I always feel
like guilty by coming Japan and not
knowing anime or I just growing up Japan
was everything to me it was so such
amazing mystical wonderful country
everything I used everything I did every
crazy was Japanese in some way from
Pokemon to Nintendo Sony my first
camcorder that I often used was sharp
Panasonic after that like I don't cheap
an always felt like a country I wanted
to try and visit and go to but being
British if you look at a map of where
Japan is whether you care we're not
going North American viewers though
obviously it's still pretty damn far
it's not that fast and water yeah Japan
so damn far and so I thought I'm not
gonna go there but then I thought about
teaching English and Japan came up as an
option and it was the only country I
ever thought I'd want to teach English
in and actually immerse myself learn
about the culture soon a nutshell that's
kind of it
so you know before all of that like you
were already per set on like leaving the
UK at one point or absolutely they
always wanted to live overseas and
travel somewhere so what would have been
your second option if you never asked
that second option yeah I don't know if
there was a second option idea it was
kind of like Japan or nothing
oh wow just Japanese culture really
excitedly like all the stuff I seen
about it but okay I watched your first
video last night I was doing some
research and the vibe you gave off
almost is like alright lads I'm in Japan
I just ended up in Japan might [ __ ]
around and stay a little bit I got the
impression I just thought he was like a
thing where you're like alright [ __ ] it
might move Japan satellite the vibe I
had got from the video I guess but
obviously hearing that I'm like kind of
shocked but then I could also see a
British person not wanting to seem like
obsessed with something because that's
uncool British cool ya know it's not
that I mean the trouble he's like yeah
most people come to Japan are interested
on the anime and stuff yeah I mean
putting a Japanese classic University on
the side and I was not the only one in
that class that didn't really like I'm
learning Japanese and I'm the only one
who doesn't watch anime you need to know
animation to live in Japan to be into
that I think I was just drawn to like
how the cultures very different one of
the things I studied was cultural
discourse which is so boring that I
never talked about it and I was really
into the cultural discourse and language
and Japan kept coming up in the studies
and that was actually one reason I never
talked about that just cuz it's so
boring social discourse just like how
everything in the culture just is just
so different the way people communicate
right so indirectly there's just so me
there's such a different mindset in
Japan that is so in common
comprehensively different to most other
countries and I started learning about
that and I really wanted to kind of
immerse myself in that yeah I mean that
I think that's definitely true
especially having moved here and lived
here for a little bit we discuss there
like a bit on like our last podcast
where we discussed Japan so what was it
that made you decide to make like
YouTube videos about Japan or was it
just you you decided to like kind of
vlog your experiences or plan that
before yeah just like you turned up and
you're like this seems like good idea no
I do the back of my head I think I'd
always been interested in filmmaking but
I kind of kind of threw that dream away
because it's quite hard to get into the
film industry in the year but then I go
here I make huge channel and actually
before I got to Japan
it wasn't many huge she was in Japan and
I was like I'm really excited what's
Japan like they weren't on YouTube and
there wasn't a whole lot going on no
offense to the youtubers in japan free
then free 2012 it wasn't much nothing
okay maybe I can fill that void and take
my hobby of filmmaking and my dream that
I've forgotten and actually can I use
that and do something with it
so I hadn't watched a whole lot achieve
up until that point right I kind of draw
a lot of my influences from British TV
and are the rather than other kind of
vloggers and other youtubers yeah yes
because like I think anyone can agree
they're like if you watch any one of
your videos and it deftly has more of
like a TV vibe than like a traditional
like hey guys yeah it doesn't feel like
an iteration on YouTube which a lot of
channels that have come into it newer do
feel like they're trying to emulate a
style on it whereas I feel like maybe
that is what is certainly unique about
your your take on I mean blogging side
me was met the idea of making like a
crappy low-budget TV show Rob yeah seems
like my guiding star it's it get gave
off the impression of like a BBC not not
BBC show but like a short you'd seem
like on on a show or like a news
broadcast about Japan or about a
different culture yeah that's I think I
think that's what like how I found your
content at first and you mentioned being
one of the first people to do vlogs
about or not vlogs but like videos about
high quality walls high clarity books do
you remember the scene back then of what
vlogs were like it was like the shaky
cattle yeah 2012 right oh Jesus I mean
yeah PS Russia and that's like yes
Russia was probably laid behind those
were good times I feel like that was the
golden era of YouTube a sense I feel
like every era has its own thing to it
and I think it's easy to look back and
be like that was the best time forget
about all those people filming that TV
playing call how could we call that the
Golden Age I mean stick a camcorder in a
shoot or because I think this was
showering Japan the only like vlogger
really before there's a fee there was a
Michaela give me a break man
Victor yeah yeah like I've come to like
know a lot of the J blogs that leave
here like scene slate the J vlogging
community is so small in a sense that
like once you know a few you basically
know everybody enough eventually and
like yeah I mean you know meeting Chris
and like meeting a bunch of all the like
smoke newer and older yeah bloggers it's
like it's really interesting to see like
just how big it actually is because on
the surface I think if you if you don't
know a lot of them right does just seem
like Chris and a few other people yeah
whereas late there's just so many and
that's a JBoss there isn't you can kind
of easily stay in a bubble if you want
to yeah how do you feel about the
current J walking scene there I don't
know really I don't I'm friends with a
lot of them but I don't I don't watch
that much
I don't cuz I live in Japan you know I
don't really wanna watch other other
Japan stuff I do my stuff I spent ages
working on a video in a room I upload it
and then I go off and drive around the
mountains and go
why yeah I've kind of felt like to be
disconnected from it a little bit do you
ever like see a video made by the jave
ocular like sometimes you scrap it if
that happens or what's the common virus
I was thinking of doing a
day-in-the-life series and then youtuber
called Paulo yeah yeah oh yeah yeah a
carbon copy right yeah and that's fair
enough he's done it well if you didn't
do it well I think it's something
similar like with yourself well you did
like it yeah you died you did like a day
in the life of late abroad in Japan on a
bicycle
no no like you I think the thumbnail was
like you in a Shinkansen oh yeah I did
it once many years maybe he got the
inspiration ha ha no no we did it's
definitely I feel like where is maybe
maybe like channeling Paulo is I feel
like it's more really a hundred percent
based on what is happening in the video
and what's being shown but I feel like
at least with your channel there's a lot
of your humor which is kind of crucial
to the style yeah to the video so really
maybe if you did do it if you added your
own human trip but then you don't get in
the way of the thing that you're not I
know yeah that's my main thinking he's
done it well he's covered like
interesting people when I say dare my
life don't mean me that's literally my
life matching up socks it's doing
nothing no because yeah I feel like
exactly the same where I there was a
point when I tried to watch like every
other anime youtuber everyone everyone
in my sphere and then it just got to a
point when it just became like stressful
cuz you just watch other youtubers it's
like oh man I wanted to do that topic or
I wanted to do that topic um and now
like pretty much I just keep up with
what my mates are doing and you know
some other people yeah but like did you
yet guys ever go through that phase as
well I did but then like very quickly I
realized like just how again like same
enjoyable just how broad
anime YouTube he is and how many topics
the work of it so like yeah yeah at that
time I was like oh man I wanted to do
that I do I went to that day but then
after a while I was just like [ __ ] it
people have already done this I'll
[ __ ] do it like I do my own twist on
it and I'm sure my wanting to enjoy it
and if they're you know if they're so
willing to be like oh this is just a
copy or so its own I'm just like well
the problem I was doing a video earlier
this year about things I'll never
understand about Japan
things I'll never understand about Japan
was about Ted and I was like [ __ ] can't
never understand that I still did well
yeah ever every watched money you she
was excited from you to I think and I
never be worried about overlapping at
all cuz I was pretty confident that I
was doing the stupidest [ __ ] that was
available so I was like I was like no
one's is willing to embarrass themselves
as me so I'm pretty sure you were kind
of an anomaly I mean you were called the
93 percent for a reason at one point my
audience for some reason I know why I
was was 93 percent female yeah which in
the attitude what was unheard yeah
because she was normally it's a massive
sausage fest it's you know dude talking
about you know which Naruto powerup is
the strongest you know wow that's quite
impressive is it no it's like 6040 now
so it's impressive I mean at the time
yeah I guess I mean because I was
covering melee anime shows while doing
stuff I've seen like prank calls anime
characters from shows they were like
more female or and that's the secret
doing the British you know like British
Butler
you know like Sebastian yes you know I
would like call up McDonald's and tell
them oh my gosh it's not working and I
think like the reason why like Conan did
excel on that his big nose again now
what he was tapping into an audience
like a female demographic that literally
none of us were tapping into yeah I feel
like a lucky one you were really like
honor issue like they don't they never
think outside of like okay if it's the
anime community at that time it was
either talk about anime or make a show
where you talk over anime and you make
them say things they would say Yeah
right
and no one was really trying to think
like what else can you do with this
medium and then talk about shows yeah
yeah I was like well I kind of like the
bridging which is like you read um anime
but yes a horrible things but I didn't
like how that took like a month to make
so I was like all right I'll go in the
middle
I'll take these characters and just
prank call people with them yeah and do
the voices and it kind of is like a
happy medium of like messing around but
also I can interject a lot of my
personality into it slowly built it up
so yeah but I haven't done prank calls
and so long there was about say cuz for
me like I do you guys remember how you
started to find your style because like
when I can please start when I started
YouTube mine was completely here's I'm
gonna try and repulsive punctuation and
this is just my I remember your old
Twitter bio because I do I'd assault
with a bio Rahzel how do you remember it
was like because I think I remember
click on it for some reason it was like
I'm that other fast-talking British guy
that not yeah tea or something because I
was always my top comment so I was I was
just like let's just let's just refer to
this in the bio but like the more I did
videos I guess the more than my own
style evolved cuz I started YouTube 2007
so like mine was out right like near the
beginning of YouTube so the one there
wasn't really anyone else to play off of
so I just kind of copied who I was
watching at the time and there wasn't
many creators on the platform but in
terms of you guys did you how did you
find your style how did you start out I
guess do you almost feel that like
YouTube style is like you just try a
bunch of things and then one or two of
them work and you just like iterate it
and then you try again with a bunch of
iterations of like that thing that you
did yourself not copying other people
but like so you have a success with one
thing then like okay what worked about
that how do I then try and bunch of new
things then slowly shot to figure out
okay this isn't working
this isn't working I don't know what do
you think cuz it was just very different
because I'll see ya
mine's more based off British TV like
Charlie Brooker for example the right
style I love Charlie yeah yeah oh my god
III take inspiration from screen white
as well it might in my year in review
year interviews was directly influenced
by Charlie Brooker [ __ ] fantastic and
that is one of my key influences so
that's something I would have watched
yeah and then when I sat down front the
camera I thought that's why I want a
channel and it's when I'm on camera it's
kind of not made more like a kind of
more obviously energetic song yeah stick
bit yeah individual I'm not that
monstrous off cap well your style
sometimes it's almost like reminiscent
of like David Mitchell in terms of that
very like dry sarcasm you know that's
like it's just so beautiful laughs David
Mitchell you know without the like
depressing look sometimes the David
Mitchell has it's pretty depressing like
sad faces bridge TVs my main influence I
wouldn't say actually I've been
influenced by another YouTube channel as
such as a result but what I have found
is over the years I started off quite
strong in that character and I lost it
because I started going from
commentating on things in a room doing
more travel stuff library you can't be a
cynical sarcastic [ __ ] you have to
be nicer when you're out and about doing
things so I lost that but this year by
virtue of the virus by virtue of being
indoors mode can I come back to
rediscovering that character and who I
actually enjoy being on camera I think
we do you say that cuz I did a video in
like two videos I've done I have some
songs try and do some videos outside in
Japan like out of my bedroom basically
yeah I did a video in a house club oh
okay thank you thank ya and that was
really difficult because the my back of
my head was like I've worn a crack jokes
at the dumb stuff that they're doing or
the really cringey moments but at the
same time I don't want to offend them
yeah it's kind of striking that balance
of like I'm playing the fool where I'm
like oh that's odd isn't it you know
that's kind of strange huh Benja moving
on yeah it's a tough one you can't yeah
that sort of cynical sarcastic side
trying to strike that dance
you kind of got to be like rhetorical in
a sense and not just be like yeah if
you're in your bedroom and you're
watching a video you're commentating on
something you can really just go in and
yeah full-on jokes right so it's trying
to channeled almost that British sense
of like just a little like little jab
but saying a point that's not a cat I
mean let's talk about that what it was
what was the whole experience like for
you like is there anything off camera or
anything like I really heard that I only
heard the stories you told me that was a
lot of things cuz you do we all went
there to scouted Bay before Dan yeah do
we happen to be in Shinjuku and I was
gonna film that the next day and we were
like we just like rock up to this Rose
Club and see what's up I didn't like it
looks sketch right like it was pretty oh
yes they were very very nice to me but I
won't I will be honest and say that the
it was a little you know no I mean I
remember going to the area and I'm like
I'm normally I don't fear for my safety
in Japan and a really sketchy area of
Shinjuku yeah yeah yeah and uh I mean
what what do you want to know about this
experience we were recording for four
hours okay so it was a four hour shoot
so we started before they opened up and
then we went through the whole thing and
they like the whole point was that like
I wanted to I like actually try and talk
to customers yeah cuz it might had it I
wanted that to kind of be like Louis
Theroux asked why he brilliant he puts
himself in this yeah yeah yeah I really
wanted to put myself in a situation that
was really uncomfortable for me and uh
yeah so I was introduced around by the
main guy called tiser and I'm very
thankful he showed me around I don't
think many people in the comments liked
him there and why he made a lot of jokes
and we caught a lot of them it was very
very insistent and like bashing my looks
a lot and I was I was rolling with it I
was like yeah yeah do you think do you
think he was trying to be funny and just
failing or was it like was this like
that I think he was also maybe a little
light acting up for the camera I think
maybe he's like oh this new kid comes in
yeah who's got subscribers let's show
him like you know what's what
like he's hot no way assert dominance
you know that the the way that they like
attract women I found was like so
blatantly jaffa B yeah you know what I
mean it's like it was um really opposite
from like West and hitting on like they
would literally the moment this girl sat
down right they were like yo your heart
you're beautiful what you're doing all
you like what are you doing they were
like the moment they sit down they start
hitting that forward yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you know those girls and the problem
is is that like they wanted me to like
sit down and immediately like start
hitting on them and I was like so like
do I can't do that - yeah but it's
restraint so like the way the hosts work
at least these guys like the whole thing
was like you know but of them up get
them to you know buy you drinks at them
online talk to them take them out on
dates and afterwards be like hey you
coming at the host club tonight like it
was really like weird I guess
superficial yeah it was very superficial
and III really I felt understood how
like a lot of these girls were really
into them because there's one girl in
the video who was like adamant that she
was gonna marry the host obviously he
was like yeah of course you are you know
because she just spent $10,000 on a
champagne bottle so yeah it's gonna be
like of course you're my future did she
do to be able to afford such frivolous
expenditure what they told me off-camera
was that they tend to be in the same
kind of industry oh so it's kind of like
they're like the same five tumblr
artists just giving each other search
just giving each other the same
Commission the circular economies abuse
you might be working a like most of them
were working in so plans don't know is
an under board kind of it's it is if you
google it it's a process prostitution
yeah it's legal prostitution
yeah actually so a lot of them tended to
be also you know prostitutes yeah and I
guess that's why they were maybe okay
with the superficiality of it all right
you've been to a snack bar or hostess
club or anything before that I'd went to
like a maid cafe and ass about it
I've never been to anything where it was
life like that because they were like on
the moment these girls come in they get
a eight or nine minutes each each host
wrote about our hit on these girls so
one goes in and then you know he does
this thing immediately after he walks
the next house comes in starts hitting
on and then after like an hour right she
is who she likes
so speed dates if literally speed dating
but a lot of the girls I think they're
coming for their cuz you get like two
hours of free like by ten bucks for all
you can drink
right so a lot of the people a lot of
people come in do the two hours and then
just never come back yeah but yeah no I
remember it was really really really
painful to try and hit on these girls
because I was trying to hit on them
through a translator I don't know it's
like it's like this distance we're
seeing that as well I'm like you look
really pretty
[Laughter]
they would say it they would say it back
and if you like Thanks and I'm like just
like just imagine being the translator
and just like that's less a next level
of third wheel the whole thing is like
obviously I'm also drinking a lot of
alcohol cuz the main host was adamant on
getting me smashed yeah and so it looked
like we were drinking water but it was
just like shorty in between the shots
that you were constantly doing was
strong zero oh God and they would drink
strong zero like I said world wide they
every every time they'd have to go to a
girl they would have to finish all that
drink that they would make as well those
were always like 12% or high spirits
right and this I remember they were
telling me the hosts in Japan they were
like like vomiting every single night
from alcohol I mean if you're mixing
strong zero like champagne and sham
shots yeah cuz they made me download
like a half bottle of champagne oh my
god how much was that worth how much
that there on the menu it costs like I
think it was like nine thousand or
something were you sick after no I
wasn't lyin up I went to like little
lamb right after a night a great meal so
bring up an awful
but it was yeah so that was like nine
you drank like $4,000 worth of champagne
yeah and then a bunch of drinks in
between that the shots were like $30
each and the drinks were like $50 each
would you ever do a video like that
Chris well I was thinking about doing it
so I'm not gonna put myself that's what
I thought
I wondered why no J vlog has had done it
but I felt like none of them would be
willing to do yeah I'm not cutting like
five years of my life expectancy they do
it but like they all owned like
apartment in central Shinjuku because
they make like average like $10,000 yeah
yeah yeah like and a lot of them said
it's their family so a lot of them are
just like making the money while it's
good I guess and they are getting out
that the coolest guy there was the vice
president who like wasn't a Hearst and I
thought he was like my father hardest as
well he was like the 34 he looked like
every like bishi anime yeah and he was
really nice he was really open he was
giving us a whole tour telling us
everything about the club
whilst the other guys just wanted to see
me fail with the women cuz I remember
the main guy was like oh yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna you're gonna be supporting
me and I turn right in the house I go
over and he's like oh yes oh no you have
to do the I'll support you I'm like what
I was lied to
yeah and we cut a lot of the stuff cuz I
got really [ __ ] drunk what's like the
looks like the craziest place you're
like willing to like go film in Japan no
I've always wanted film the snack bar or
hostess bar because you've done this one
are they it's basically what you've just
described but the other way around with
girls and guys okay far less expensive
the way I used to live in Yamagata it's
like the only thing to do you go to
another car and the second place you
always go for New York I party is
hostess club or snack bars can like a
cheaper variant I've been to a snack bar
before yeah and there's nothing seedy
about them there's no nice eat about
hostess I mean it was a little bit seedy
for me because almost like 1600 in the
middle of nowhere in Hokkaido
cuz I wasn't working in ski fields and
my boss was like hey let's go to snack
bar and I'm like I'm like four years on
the right I win
and soon oh that's like 16 year old kids
just like sitting there you know just
like sipping
you know beer or whatever and the mama
who's like a who's that's the name that
they give to like the the main hostess
of the snack box yeah yeah she just sat
right next to me and she's like so how
old are you my boss at the time it was
like shit-faced already because he
couldn't hold his leg he's like oh he's
26 and and at the moment he said that I
was like I'm getting kicked out there's
no way she's gonna look at me and be
like yeah you're 26 year old but no the
mom I just looked at me was like oh you
look for a young 26 year old it's a find
if you say you're over 20 they don't
question it they're like I'm cool cuz
cuz like in Asia especially like if
you're is because you cuz you're like
half Australian as well so they just
assume you're [ __ ] all wood as [ __ ]
thankful for my yeah yeah yes I was like
thank God I look like five years older
than I actually am yes all have been
some deep [ __ ] otherwise but no but the
stuff was fun like it's way more chill
than like what I assume a host club
would be easy I mean you just sit down I
have to take friends to one just to
Surprise them it comes to Pam for the
first time because they sit down and
there's like two girls other sides and
their cigarette my friends are awkward
because it's a concept that doesn't
exist really you know cuz yeah I think I
think yeah it described out someone in
the UK I think people to think that's
kind of like I mean the closest thing I
could think of in like the UK is
probably like a strip club that's that's
thought but no but it's I'm not saying
that is but it's like the closest
experience I can think of just for like
a very broad term hostess place cuz I
won't be really yeah and then they'll
make you sing karaoke songs they won't
make you drink a disturbing amount of
there's no quite as bad as what you do
yeah they they definitely seem really
sleazy the host clubs and I believe
there's like a lot of them are owned by
you know
sketchy people
you know the games by Sega those people
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure a lot of
them are owned by that because they just
kind of like operate under their own
yeah yeah yeah I mean that's where I was
so impressed that they were just want to
be like yeah come on in film it all man
yeah I don't know how you got permission
though that that easily
what happened good connection is that
yeah I think our producer Maylene best
best producer has every connection Japan
apparently talked to a host host was
like yeah I want to start my youtube
channel so that and them that and
apparently if you're like the number one
host in the club you have a lot of like
yeah that's constantly changing so next
week you could be like I have no say
right so this guy was like oh yeah I'm
bringing this guy with a film crew take
care of him and to be fair everyone was
really like nicely there was a film a
lot of stuff like how they when they
were talked about earnings and start it
was film but we cut that but they let us
like in on listening to it and who was
winning the Young's and stuff and they
take it really seriously they compete
against other host clubs to see how is
getting the most money between them and
we're talking like disturbing amounts of
money like I think one guy for is the
one who gets the most is Roland I know
it's dead okay cuz okay on one one one
guy for his birthday they were telling
me he got like $60,000 on his birthday
because on your birthday ever for us to
buy you drinks and stuff we're in the
wrong business they asked me you know
they asked me they're like how much you
earned for like having a million
subscribers in like a month and they
were like if you're starting YouTube
channel for the money don't bother it
was at that moment that I've never
regretted but not speaking Japanese yeah
any moment oh my [ __ ] just come in here
like part-time you know what I mean yeah
feel like they're like oh yawn $1 per
subscriber right that's that's that's
how I was that's how the YouTube economy
was all right sorry I never like I
thought like I had a nice comfy earning
until they like just [ __ ] in front of
all the hosts whoa wow that's pathetic
that's cute that's cute
yeah cuz I remember I watched your video
where you went balls deep into a Yazdi
Allsteel of hotel
oh yeah that was a great video the owner
is like a friend of a friend and he was
just the most hilarious man let's play
sex is the ultimate one lion sales pitch
for anything
let's tend to be like the easiest time
I've had recording in Japan is when you
know the owner and he's totally chill
yeah yeah you have to go through like
seven companies and everyone has to yeah
III did a video and say where but there
was like seven people watching me the
whole time like corporate hope I know
the feelin and I was just like alright
can I make a joke like am I allowed to
do this when you know the owner of
somewhere in Japan attracts everything
yeah that was really down-to-earth guy
he like you gave me a goodie bag
goodie bag is that the most fun you've
had filming in outside or in Japan zone
certainly up there it's like top three
moment and they did like the opening the
video he does these monkey bars across
the page I had a shot of a bed right you
can't see him doing the monkey bars so
it looks really daunting to the love
hotel video the first ten seconds had a
shot of a bed and loads of people
message me like you bastard I was
playing this video the love that so many
times what would you say is like you're
like so far your favorite video that's a
really broad it was
the one with you mean Joey of course me
about that I was like my dream has come
true the most what is it the most
haunted have YouTube channel chills
right yeah yeah yeah yeah what was the
video was like top top 5 YouTube waiters
don't wait that went too far yeah too
far do you know chills have you heard
his stuff before you know I thought I
was I didn't even watch a video they
messaged me I'm like can we use your
videos I was like yes you have your way
with my video I was so like on ik meme
are you a meme Lee I was so happy when
like there's nothing more invigorating
when just in that voice they say is your
name Joey the anime man October 16 2018
is when Chris bikes with his friend Joey
in search of an eerily event in tunnel
that's rumored to be haunted
life was the best
I got a flashback I ever did that host
copy I got an email from a prostitution
website and a bad did you actually they
were like and they'd sent me videos of
like on lively of people filming
ah-ha-ha-ha cover they were like this is
what you can do if you want sound legal
I was on the train and I was like yeah
I'll open this link for some reason I
open this thing it was a Raging Blast
but yeah they were like if you want
we'll arrange escorts for you and you
can film the whole thing and I'm like
from what from which process of this
needs to like get like approval from
brasses to use their logo is that
something that I need that's not
straight I should find me I'll find the
email if we had to take a break whatever
but like it was they were they were
basically like saying if ya if you want
to order any pasta choose to make a
video about it in Japan
Desmond yeah I can totally like I don't
know why I can totally see you doing a
video or it's like I tried escorts in
Japan with my prostitute that's like
peak youtuber clickbait here right I
tried to be an escort gone wrong
no Gong sex you offered me on the
website yeah and I looked at it and it
was like it was legit there was like
videos of like like someone had like a
secret GoPro yeah something and they
were filming it and it was really
doesn't sound cool it was very disturbed
yeah and I quickly turned it off and
when they started talking about what act
they were gonna perform for what price
and I just found it so odd that they
watch my host club video and that they
were like this seems like a natural
evolution I would like to hire an escort
CD [ __ ] given your relatively short time
in Japan the government please leave me
alone
yeah I did worry if like the host club
would like raise any like suspicions or
anything but I was like [ __ ] it I think
it's a really interesting concept if I
hand go well it should be fine yeah yeah
that was that took forever to come ahead
it but they have enough about that
anyway yeah I mean like you know she has
gone real when you see the liveleak logo
like I didn't even see it wasn't on
lively it was Ali it was a link to a
video with a live legal so what do you
guys think of the state of YouTube right
now then right in that guy I'm dumb I'm
just jumping right into it okay I hire
prostitutes I mean you're doing I
imagined juji imagine died you don't
have any issues really with YouTube I
know coming out this week about why I
hate Japanese TV and I've got clips from
Japanese TV in it that's the first time
my video could get bug it for years even
get like demonetised
few times 1 2 3 years ago yeah not
recently maybe for swearing event is
flaring Fukushima documentary got a
little bit buggered for being a
sensitive topic yeah I spent like two
three weeks on this amazing docume
I was really proud of it and then Lucci
was like night we're not praying that
doesn't know about no use that's the
worst feeling in the world
yeah I was amazing video by the way I
don't but like luckily loads of people
on Twitter seem to push the video and
then I contact you [ __ ]
okay and they did something it kind of
released it and then these started going
up and so it's kind of doing right now
holy [ __ ] actually works watch this and
it works the first story I've ever heard
of someone contacting YouTube especially
about like getting multi monetize or
age-restricted or something I'm getting
that it works and it works
they removed like 200 copyright claims
from my channel twice so that was nice
of them yeah I mean I was surprised I
mean that was a [ __ ] miracle that
yeah yeah my whole channel I was using
an outro song that I bought a license to
turned out this guy made it didn't have
a license to did so I had a bogus
license and I had like a hundred and
forty videos all my revenue overnight
which got taken and I beat it the first
time because it was being copyright
claimed by him the second time was being
copyright claimed by Warner Brothers Oh
Sal on a night was like a nightmare so
had to re-render all my videos out with
a silent thing and YouTube did a thing
where they like swap it with the live
yeah yeah yeah which they never do they
rarely do it and the only reason they
did it was cuz I talked [ __ ] about my
partner manager in one of the videos
actually not bad that could have gone
either way that could've been like yeah
[ __ ] you there right at the time I was
so frustrated like my god like I just
lost thousands of dollars yeah every
month right sir
but they worked with me and we got it
done but that's the only time I've had
like a positive experience cuz like the
thing about YouTube is that it's just
sometimes it's terrifying just to put
your entire like livelihood on someone
in someone else's shoes or someone
else's hands because I remember the the
biggest heart I've ever got which was
like I think was last year where I
logged onto YouTube and I just had this
message that said your account has been
terminated
they'll have to monetize right the whole
channel um I think I don't know I got to
monetize I remember cuz like mr. piece
yeah that was that one somewhere
everyone involved like I don't know I
could upload anything yeah I don't know
five videos or even up like I can't
remember exactly what happened because
it was like a blur because you know when
you read the message when your lighting
out there you like what do I do like how
did this happen like it's it wasn't like
a copyright claim
it wasn't anything I'd seen before it
was just like it just basically shut
down took everything right yeah I just
took everything and do you know what you
know what sucks is that now to be like
to really get YouTube's attention you
just have to make as much noise as you
can on Twitter which is the key yeah it
sucks though if they don't have a good
support system
you basically have to hope that you can
make enough noise and you have enough of
a following or social media presence on
another platform aside from YouTube to
make enough noise on Twitter um it was
just something wrong their algorithm
that they had mistaken god why do I know
more about this near they mistaking you
because you slob am i footage that he
was reusing like content and I think
they demonetized channels that use too
much footage from rows and they mistakes
it fell she not being fair use I think
is what happened if I'm right I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
case yeah yeah I don't know why I
remember this so vividly I don't know
what you remember about than me more of
God [ __ ] than him I know his bio yeah it
was just a blur for me cuz it was just
that was the most stressful day because
it was like 24 hours yeah you know
that's fair enough 24 hours but 24 hours
just like logically you know maybe this
is probably gonna be fixed you know
it'll be fine by tomorrow yeah 24 hours
oh no it was long 24 hours in my life
because actually it was the second time
that my channel had been deleted so my
the first time my channel got deleted
was in 2011 which is why if you go to my
like
oldest video it's from 2011 and that's
because I had to reload everything
um and that was you know that was only
back when I had 30,000 subscribers but
like I mean at that time 30,000 porty
felt like the world no no it was it was
and that was like that was the most like
my heart sank lower then like anyone had
ever like I'd ever fell before just just
seeing
years of your work just be just like go
down the drain and it's completely out
of your control so that's
like the one downside of being a
youtuber the biggest downside I'd say
for for me sense of it all being outside
your control yeah 2017 was a bad year
when they start D monetizing everything
oh my god they're so trigger-happy with
that way I've been between the ye Joey
you you had loads of videos hundred of
my videos got yeah I had like over a
thousand videos at that point and I
think over 300 videos got demonetised it
was like overnight I'm related to
everyone
it was absolutely chaos then what's day
trigger again I've Logan Paul suicide
forest was it yeah I thought I told it
was PewDiePie yeah I wasn't directly his
fault but I think that was the iceberg
I I think sorry my it might have been a
combination of the two I don't know but
it was right after the Wall Street
Journal made that article on PewDiePie
yeah yeah that was definitely work too
that was another thing I was just kind
of talk about the upcoming video okay
because I was brought onto Japanese TV
on to Mesmer sheet Adobe which is are
the biggest morning TV show and I was
like forced to like defend Heat all
foreign youtubers in the name of Logan
Paul just kept saying that and they went
home to Tokyo I've done my bit was this
recent all know that was in 2018 was
that are you YouTube open the door to
apartment they're like are you YouTube I
wait to do that three times got the
first ones but yeah yes Chris brought
met them into my apartment and it's real
I mean yeah I've had some pretty late
cuz I've been on Japanese TV twice right
at this point and man I don't know about
you like you've been on Japanese TV a
few times too yes
many times quite a lot
what for every time one was about Briggs
it they interviewed me on brakes before
and after the vote they ask you what
doing is gonna happen and they had me
like pretend I was disappointed
obviously I was forced to step my laptop
with my head like this going looking
really a motor made you do that they
made me look really spare like am I
looking at the laptop BBC website going
right because they found out because
obviously YouTube made they were like oh
you cheaper hold a camera as well while
you're doing it holding a camera be like
yeah it's terrible I mean that's the one
thing I [ __ ] hate about the two times
that I was on Japanese TV he's like yeah
love right like I knew Japanese TV was
[ __ ] scripted out of its arse
yeah just the extent to which it is
scripted it's just ridiculous absolutely
like the I remember one time I was on
this the first time I was on the on a TV
program here in Japan was uh they did
like a street interview in Harajuku yeah
and it was like one of those it was a TV
show I was like a debate show Oh
quote-unquote debate show where they
would like gather like 30 different
foreigners from like different countries
okay and they would put them in to a
studio to basically like there's like 30
gauges and there's like 30 like Japanese
schools and we've have to like debate on
like really like controversial [ __ ] I
think one of the topics was like should
Japan legalize marijuana and like I got
you know done on the street interview
and I guess like the the crew at the
time really liked my answers that they
were like hey we might call you back and
like invite you to the actual studio
because apparently I was like the only
Australian that they ever interview so I
was like you have to come in to
represent Australia as a country cuz
like every guy's you know what
representing a different Western country
and like I said that I did a whole video
on this which went viral but like I sat
in the studio essentially and they even
like before the show started
they gave me like this full online like
40 page script of the entire show yeah
okay in this section the host is gonna
like call up and be like hey does anyone
have an opinion you're the only one
that's gonna put their hand up to like
give an opinion yeah and they told me
that five minutes before we started
filming the goddamn show so I'm just
like okay I have to remember at allit
like 1 hour and 27 minutes I have to put
my hand up to give an opinion about the
legalization of marijuana at the end
they didn't even like get to that
question Oh
literally it was like a two-and-a-half
hour recording and the whole time I just
sat this out so you didn't even say
anything I didn't say anything
the whole time and they paid me 50 bucks
for it i sat in the studio silently for
two and a half hours to just look pissed
off because I'm hearing these other
arguments about like why it shouldn't be
legalized why should be legalized and
it's the most like rudiment really basic
argument that I've ever heard yeah it's
like anybody with a it's like anybody
with a [ __ ] brain can come up with
this discussion and explain and I'm just
sitting there just angrily like waiting
for my cue and it's never coming I'm
just like I really want to tell these
people to shut the [ __ ] up about the
damn awesome this is not coming so it's
like I even like tones of the guy in the
show you can actually see it in the show
actually owns of the guy I'm just like
I'm supposed to say something in this
part and the guys just like yeah I am
too waiting who we see next to like what
cuz what country were they replica it
was like it was either American or
Canadian it was a Canadian guy that's
wrong as a Canadian guy and he's like
yeah yeah like I was for the
legalization of marijuana because
obviously it's like all for that he's
like yes I was I was gonna say something
too and after the show we like bonded
over that was just like [ __ ] this show
they like brought us in like they
brought us in as only two hours earlier
and I'm like we didn't have to wait this
long Jesus and it's like we basically
wasted an entire evening for me to just
publicly humiliate myself by sitting on
Japanese TV was just like the biggest
resting [ __ ]
get fifty bucks you've got a video out
of it you've got a viral video out of it
that viral video otto would go he got
peak youtuber clickbait that's the thing
right if you if you have a shitty
situation if you can get a video out of
it thing is is that that video like
pushed me to over a million sobs oh
actually I got a good question for you
guys
what's the one time you click bait it
that you're like even you look at that
video you like oh man I'm disappointed
to myself for going for click baiting
about hard you have the have you ever
click your to prefer yeah yeah probably
my most successful video twelve things
not to do in Japan that is still to this
day on my recommended even though I've
watched it already I think though with
that video the reason why did so Wells
not because the clickbait boy you know
when you released it yeah early step boy
[ __ ] I think I released it before Logan
did oh my god that's like you know 20%
of them Ryan well because literally I
think it was like seven out of the 12
things you said Paul he didn't even have
to make a statement like like a
different statement like that video just
spoke for itself
yeah good old Logan poll we got me a
viral hit any great great man like it's
like it just comes down to like what
even is click bait anymore fryer because
like I think as long as you deliver on
the title that is the main thing like
the video I talked about earlier what
what was it what I the one that you did
that I did watch man like you know Japan
what I'll never understand about Japan
that sounds quite clickbait in that you
know this thumbnails be going it was
some beer looking really shocked it's a
bit vague but as long as the subject and
all the content delivers on the title I
think it's okay to have a provocative
clickbait style tight I mean yeah it's a
good argument because like clickbait
what is clickbait Indian is there's
there's like different levels in my eyes
you know what I mean though feel like it
happened again and it's you going
I'm so sorry and it's it's literally is
flight getting yeah I think it was
called like no it was called like we're
so angry and then in brackets I'm sorry
just like my flight got canceled and
like Allegiant airlines I watched that
video yeah without flight for no [ __ ]
reason and we missed our convention to
Finland I watch that video I was like
1.2 million views this video but 20
title no doubt yeah you know there's
always the content delivers and gives
viewers something it's a game yeah total
I mean I knew what I was doing when I
titled it that way you know but I don't
know like that's the thing right like
every year like I I feel like five years
ago on YouTube you could spot a cliff
Bait title from your building miles away
yeah like you did yeah like that was
like a certain type of thumbnail a
certain structure to the title where
it's like yeah yeah I'm gonna get baited
if I click on this yeah nowadays like I
think people are just getting waist
smarter at titles and thumbnails so like
I think clickbait has been getting
smarter as well or like how to like get
people's attention with a really really
unique title or thumbnail right I feel
like part of being a youtuber is just
knowing the meta the matter is what I'm
calling it you know what I mean you're
like I remember if back a few years ago
if he had the word prank or gone wrong
or gone [ __ ] sexual did you get
[ __ ] millions of views easy right but
now that does that the [ __ ] you know
what I mean is that there's a great
quote I remember from Philip DeFranco
yeah and he was talking in a video of
his waist talking about clickbait like
filly deal like back in the day was like
the master of clickbait yeah and I think
she's tits in the thumb yeah right yeah
but like he said something along the
lines of like you know with the title
and thumbnail as long as the content is
good and there's at least some kind of
like content that you can take away from
it it really doesn't matter what the
title and thumbnail is because at the
end of the day you have to trick your
kids and
eating their vegetables like wow that
light that actually makes a lot of sense
yeah times you might have a particular
type of content where there's just no
way you can like title of a thumbnail in
a way that will get the attention of
kids or like people with short attention
spans and so you have to be forced to
click play but as long as the content is
good and is at some level of quality
yeah I really don't think there is
anything wrong with making like a really
clean baby title that's always been my
kind of guiding philosophy because like
it's it's on YouTube is all about you
because there's so much competition the
the the [ __ ] recommended feed or the
[ __ ] homepage you gotta you gotta
like immediately stand now you can be
making what I hate about being a
youtuber is that you can have a great
[ __ ] video you know this video is a
goldmine you have no idea how to get
people to click on it yeah and like
sometimes you have a video you pour you
poured your heart and soul into and then
you get to the Tyler thumbnail you're
like [ __ ] what do I do this is something
you consider when you're all like
picking these places to visit are you
thinking about like how can I like you
know yeah well maybe the first thing I
think about is yeah that's just like a
natural instinct with you too because
I've only gotten into doing that
recently before we just make the video
that's had a good concept figure it out
but yeah I realized I was getting in
situations where videos weren't doing
too hot because people weren't clicking
oh yeah yeah yeah then once I go into
the habit of like get the title then
make the video around it alright it's
horrible to say that but you don't have
to do like yeah this island thumbnail is
by far the most important thing about
being a successful YouTube it is sad
that it's gone to that point yeah we're
like you can't just have like a banger
like if you get a low click-through rate
YouTube's like no no no that's not
getting recommended yeah 3% less
click-through rate than my home old like
even the whole like some some crazy so
you like don't try you know with me with
their like title and thumbnail so much
to say other youtubes that's like a
brand in it off itself you know what I
mean like some youtubers that can
literally title and thumbnail a video
anything and yeah like they just built
that trust that like they'll click
through yeah and I like to think that
you're
channel is very much like that in a
sense because I don't really look at an
abroad in Japan video and think like oh
that's clickbait right like I it like I
know from the get-go like what I'm gonna
get into when I see the title and that's
true but like how long have you been
doing YouTube I'm doing it eight years
as of the August this year 2012 yeah but
I've only made 200 videos I think so far
so yeah I mean I make far less videos
than like you guys right so I have to
make every video really count for
something that's to be that video I I
think a lot of people would say that
they are I mean I know a lot of people
who really speak really highly of your
content say make sense but I going on
off that do you feel like the neat like
the quality Bob raises each year with
like content that's being made in Japan
like the kind of vlog stuff or do you
feel like you're really on top of that
yeah I mean I remember about four years
in there was a channel that popped up
called only in Japan run by John dog and
he raised the bar like I used to just be
a vlog kind of yeah yeah had TV
productions like [ __ ] that's the future
that's what you are so raise my bar to
try and reach that kind of level of
quality and I've noticed since then a
lot of channels water started slowly
like creeping up as well with the sale
that kind of will say its production
value isn't as important as people think
it is the main thing is is having
content that people want to watch like
I've made lots of videos out about
traveling to interesting places but the
videos always do the best it's just me
sitting in a room giving a commentary on
some I mean that's nothing at the end of
the day right it's like it doesn't
matter how good of a camera you have how
good of a mic up how good your anything
is if you have a personality of a brick
wall no one's gonna [ __ ] watch you
yeah that's YouTube really right we if
you want to get a sterilised document of
a player documentary we can watch
something else I mean that's even like
Louis Theroux right you watch him as
well Marylou he's the host and he is
there right yeah he he doesn't like jaws
dropped doesn't judge right he's in the
way of the documentary but he gets just
enough personality well like you want it
to be his documentary you know like you
wish you watch sometimes you watch a
documentary like man I wish Louie
through I made this you know could be
like I feel like you like almost got a
really
good balance with that like I feel like
you interject your personality just
enough where it's like it's really
cements that like I really wish abroad
in Japan cup of this you know what I
mean you know the good video should be
entertaining and educational there's a
fine line to balance right and that's
the most important thing I always try
and focus on and that's what I found
really interesting when I joined you for
journey across Japan right because you
brought up the whole thing of such
quality content to a bicycle when you
when you said when you told me before
the whole thing started they're like
yeah I'm gonna try and release a video
every day and I thought back to your
production quality I'm like good [ __ ]
water when I found out that you were
editing your own videos for that I was
like is this guy insane what time Joey
met me one week who's editing those
videos and cycling cyclocross Japan for
like two months and yeah I was cycling
filming and editing it all at the same
time because I'm a real idiot even
though I had like two people who are
willing to edit with me on the journey
and a god I remember after the first day
I sat with you in your hotel room as you
were like starting to edit on me and I'm
just like you're gonna like be able to
get I think you stayed up too like we
have to get up I think the next day and
then I go 9 8 or 9 a.m. I was really
really early and [ __ ] Chris had
stayed up to like it's 5:00 a.m. what
the [ __ ] maybe like four hours sleep at
most like he's like alright guys about
to do a 15-kilometer cycle now how many
times did you do that on the trip the
videos came out every day there's every
two days every four by the engines I
once a month I think you would burn
yourself that sounds like an absolute
like fast tractor was there jury left I
was [ __ ] I saw like the rapid decline
like a mental health yeah broke my heart
is when you did you put it with ammo
that you recorded to record a video with
her that you like - she came along for
three days and
a Laker as I oh hi but Matt point I've
been cycling two months oh you want to
explain what you're in Japan is just in
case someone cycle across Japan from
Yamagata to Kagoshima about 2,000
kilometers the idea was to film every
single day and make a video and show
people bits of Japan you don't normally
see by the time Emma joined he was the
last guest in Kyushu are dead now it's a
real shame about to apologize to every
yesterday when I met my bro cause I can
only imagine like you two must have been
a yin to your end of the road right and
like just having like bad just unusable
footage which is because at the end the
day it was a it was mostly a success we
had 28 episodes by the end and the
videos with Joey it was interesting cuz
in the second half the journey we went
through like Kyoto Osaka Hiroshima and
then Jerry when he joined was like
nothing Joshua do we feel like at the
biggest nuclear power plant in the world
yeah there was nothing so we had to
improvise and make like commercials
about energy jelly what's going on here
the idea of taking a place where there's
nothing really going on right I'm trying
to infuse some sort of creative
component it was it was like a creative
challenge because we had challenges
every day top of everything else so I
had challenges every day and the first
jury joined the challenge was make a
commercial in a day where ours yeah
nothing here we have to be really
creative we find a train station where
there's a real train carriage you can go
and that was surely by chance or lucky
I'm so lost so lucky we had no idea that
this station had just a [ __ ] empty
train carriage like as a thing right
perfect and then the the the challenge
we had to be about energy jelly right so
we had we already had that that was the
only thing we had to go on yeah we just
somehow pulled it off in a day so really
well about my favorite video from the
trip
so how did the idea of the travel across
Japan like come on I was gonna ask you
that same question I was like me and
Carl at what point was that like you
like thought about it at what point were
you like okay I'm gonna actually stopped
pursuing sang this up and I had been
doing a documentary about my friend
netsuke and that monster film and edit
and I was editing for like two or three
months in a row doing this and then I
buy there now is like I need to go out I
need to do something I'd always want to
travel across Japan by bicycle and I
thought this could be fun yeah it sounds
like a like even like KC nice that
couldn't keep this schedule you know
enemy and oh yeah that's in a while yeah
that's because I like hearing that you
still edit your own videos do you I do I
do and I enjoy that like for me the
least favorite part of making a video is
the presenting aspect really that's my
you're you guys are like clearly like
really great presenters you enjoy that
what for me I do enjoy it but like the
bit that I enjoys the filmmaking aspect
FRA latest video about why I hate
Japanese TV I had to learn how to use a
blue screen in a way that I'd never done
before
okay superimpose myself into a miniature
diorama and I know every video is like a
creative challenge there's something
yeah you to be learned something need to
be discovered
yeah I don't have the kind of
personality to keep putting out like
regular content you do I think you just
you just are I think you're a
personality for it yeah I think that
understandable the filmmaking process
really grows egos provide the kind of
commentary aspects right discussing
debating things anime you have so many
topics I think it's well for us it's
more just like we get on camera we make
a fool of ourselves our audience likes
it and laughs at it I felt like a huge
like weight was lifted when I stopped
editing my own videos I felt like I
actually had like time to stop
absolutely
cuz you know I'm uploading normally like
you know every five to six like five or
six days yeah it's like constant and I
think for me God talked me into getting
an editor no I remember the exact
conversation cuz he was like when I
first like went to Japan and met him and
I was like wait you still edit your own
videos what the [ __ ] you doing like you
can hold what
no because like I had that same thing
right whereas like I actually like quite
enjoyed editing and like kind of taking
what I had filmed and like making
something you still that is some of your
own video yeah yeah my videos yeah very
much like I still enjoy like editing my
videos and I think like every time I do
going out of my videos it kind of like
reinvigorates my love flight video
making cuz yeah as cool as it is to like
higher mood on who is the editor for
this podcast MVP by the way like as much
as mood on is [ __ ] amazing at editing
my videos like there is like a little
part that just can't be real place no
matter I feel like it's a it's a job
that you can pay someone to do and it
speeds up your process and because the
thing is right I'm not an editor right
if I hire someone whose main job is
being an editor yeah you can do the job
way better than I ever did and like get
a huge way off but I feel like I love to
me a lot of your own personality can
come through in the editing as well
that's true this like like for me I
still am in very heavily involved in the
editing of my own videos but well what I
realized is that a lot of a lot of my
time spent editing is can't is just like
pure like manpower you know what I mean
it's it's it's like cutting up clips
just making the timeline usable and then
afterwards that there's that like twenty
to twenty to ten percent where you can
really add your own personality right
and and what I what I did was like let's
let's see if I can work with an editor
so he can take the workload off without
making me lose my own personality
because that was my biggest concern when
hiring an editor is like is my
personality still gonna come through in
the editing I feel that's a weakness for
me to some extent I've never and I did
actually put out like an advert on
Twitter generally I got like 500 people
could do but like but then I was editing
I was my producer documentary about the
tsunami tsunami documentary about twenty
minutes and that's something that I just
did want to cut corners I didn't have to
describe it someone want to do it myself
and dive in you know yeah I think if I
was commentary videos typically kind of
set in one location right whereas a lot
of videos I do off set over many
different like the editing is much more
intensive and yeah
complicated I mean it definitely took me
like a long time for me to finally like
give someone the reins yeah
mmm late at least with my videos like I
give my editor a hundred percent
creative freedom but that's because not
only do I know that my editor knows my
[ __ ] and like my style but also because
I myself am personally a fan of that
person's work yeah and I and I see that
person's work like I remember how I
found like mood on my editor was like he
had his own YouTube channel and I was
like this guy's [ __ ] amazing it yes
ladies sense of humor is exactly the
same as mine that was like the biggest
things finding an enter with a sense of
humor like as someone whose timing and
also one big thing in in at least my
videos is that especially at the house
club there if I to edit two that are to
cut out so much of the cringy stuff
right because I see me if I want to show
the best of yourself all right
right you'll leave that [ __ ] in and I'll
be like all right I'm like an idiot but
it but it's funny like I look like a
fool but okay
it's nice to get like a second opinion
on back content because it's like oh
actually now that you did leave it in it
is actually kind of funny and like I
would have otherwise cut it out myself
right I mean Chris your videos tend to
be really like well produced as as we've
discussed but I'm wondering like do you
like scrap any videos that you've like
filmed out like in areas I'm pretty
interested so I feel like you're a
perfectionist almost I've filmed entire
videos then video I've had videos I've
made and gone this unlisted it like I
did a video one Japanese mascots wacky
mascot so you uploaded it I got 200,000
views which is like it's a lot of ease
bit yeah it was like half and I felt
like something is wrong more people
didn't watch it I don't know I remember
this I think you were saying on Twitter
right this was like not too long ago I
think you could just see the desperation
of my eyes and I film that a very bad
time like the figure I don't either
a month into it bombed and then I'd the
mask or video and I was [ __ ] YouTube's
crazed um
it's always like that it's always like
that she was three bad days in a row oh
no I've had this conversation with
corner where you know the tool where
they show you when you upload a video
and it shows you the ranking based on
the last ten upload stats you guys watch
this won't name but you Joe makes you
feel like [ __ ] analytics like your
business rubbish and like it goes all
color red it's not even right it's gray
you know what I mean that's okay it's
red if it's because I like I just
stopped checking it like III because I
realized there is basically no winning
when it comes to check-in this tool
right because if okay the only time you
feel good if it's like number one or two
or very good I feel content and if it's
average if you're like oh let's go with
me where it's like the lost my last
video as of this video is like number
four yeah and usually it's like oh cool
it's in the top huh yeah yeah when I saw
not before I was like so like so like it
just [ __ ] we've like I just [ __ ] with
my mental health so much because she
does do that thing no it really does and
that's why I like I just had to stop
checking cuz I'm like no yeah no matter
what I come out losing ninety percent of
the time I remember when I was like
[ __ ] obsessed with the analytics
right I think every user I think every
age if it goes through that point where
they just like they just see like just
the most minor of changes and this
didn't do as well this didn't do as well
and then the moment where I'm just like
you know what [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
upload a video [ __ ] the analytics yeah
well this is like as long as I'm happy
with it [ __ ] it
I do find my mood is determined by how
well or how you know how our videos done
and this is because I do spend you know
yeah yeah I guess the stakes are higher
with you stakes are high because I make
less videos it has to perform well it
has to be good and so if it does well
I'm like yes I'm the good mood yeah in
that sense I feel like you and gone up
here what more Simran's cuz like my
upload schedule like one every two weeks
if that sometimes you know
went with a month of not uploading and
that like cured me as of filming I
haven't released a video in about one
month yeah I've been working on it for
two weeks on and off trying thank you
perfect and you're like if this if this
video is not a banger if it doesn't hear
then I've just I've just taken a month
off and I've got nothing to show for it
I feel that way so it has to perform
well so if you're watching this please
go approach you have to make sure every
video delivers yeah that's why I'm so
scared to like go to like an upload
schedule of like you guys all like you
know like if with jontron or something
like that works like once a month or
once every couple of months because I'm
just so afraid of like like the
situation of like Oh what if I out blow
in a video yeah a month in between and
it's just [ __ ] bombs I mean I feel
like why I'm you Japan huh that's what
I'm trying to like get to war it's like
trying to get towards those big videos
at the host club right yeah yeah but
those videos takes so long yes for me
because I've used to upload daily right
I don't know how anyone upload honestly
I think you have to be a psychopath my
first three years I uploaded daily like
I can see how you could kind of do that
when you're like back in universities
yeah you know what I mean you use me as
well yeah yeah so yeah yeah I was
[ __ ] easy right but like yeah I'll
play a game seven parts done for the
week yeah like it got to the point where
I realized I was doing more gaming
videos than actual anime content I'm
like okay that needs to change and so I
just scrapped all gaming content and
then I went from like a video daily to
late once every two days once every
three days now I'm like once every week
essentially once every six days old
stuff and I feel okay now because I've
like gradually put myself in that state
but I that if I went from this current
schedule of like once a week like once a
month I'd be [ __ ] myself
absolutely but like did you guys feel
really bad having to keep your schedule
because that stresses me out like if
like knowing I have to upload on a
certain time like that's that's
sometimes I I I hate having a deadline
like that because that [ __ ] with like
because because I have to think oh do I
have the creative freedom to try and do
something else you know what I mean I
mean this month I've been working a
video why I hate Japanese TV yeah yeah
I've almost finished it and I think wait
a minute what do one more scene want to
do this video for years right I've
wanted to do a Japanese TV video for
years so this is a special event for me
yeah my catalyst for doing it was do you
member on Japanese TV recently there was
a clip of someone going call of a
pending and they did a comparison they
had a Japanese lady or the tissue man
her face going caught up in this and the
tissue didn't move because the Japanese
language is so eloquent and beautiful
and then she spoke in crew disgusting
virus spreading English virus went
everywhere it was conclusive evidence
the Ashe languages it wasn't an absence
of mass testing or the widespread use of
masks it was Corp end s Americans
because I made it I made a sarcastic
tweet after I sold that clip on show
frustum where i retweeted and say like
oh yes because every foreigner in Japan
goes around asking what that was like
okay I'm doing this video now I've
wanted it for years now that is the
catalyst so that was my main driver to
do a video on why I hate Japanese to
even talk about my experiences being on
TV for me as well because I like I said
in episode 3 that like you know a lot of
my Japanese and my appreciation for
Japanese culture on the Japanese
language came from Japanese TV like what
if I wasn't watching anime I was
watching you know she's Castle like as I
as I got older and like into my high
school years I watch a lot of like talk
shows because I was just genuinely
interested in like how talk shows work
and I and I started to my growing
appreciation for that but then that
entire illusion just got completely
shattered
I went onto one of those shows and I
realized just how [ __ ] fake that [ __ ]
is the pretty very open about just like
kind of like softly anti-foreign like
not saying bad things about foreigners
viciously like yeah you're right like
they like to like just like I'll just
say it's never direct it's just like
we're not saying this your efforts but
they just happen to say the pieces like
I don't want a Pandora's box like I want
to keep it funny and on point and that
is a dark turn yeah for now
it's uncomfortable topic right people
don't is there a pan is special right
Japan is better they kind of hinted that
in the rhetoric of Japanese television
you know and but it was like no I don't
open this box
Japan exactly yeah this is a bit scared
of this video because I think it's the
first time I've been critical to some
extent about Japanese culture and that's
something you just don't do this is why
are you here leave Joe and like that you
can't really be openly critical about
Japan on your channel then but I feel
like I don't have that many criticism
the thing is I have had a very positive
experience in Japan I've never felt I've
suffered any racism in my daily life
here in eight years openly racist
unpleasant experience make no mistake I
would comment on that and I make it very
lucky my time here has been very
positive so oh yeah I mean I really
don't have much to draw from it doesn't
matter if I did though I would be the
first to comment on that because we all
know there are a lot of J vlog as well
like very quick to like me absolutely
all unlike the whole egg xenophobic like
oh I experienced the racist thing and
right yeah and sometimes I kind of wish
that they would share some restraint
when they do
sometimes you watch it and it's like
that wasn't really like worth talking
about life in the supermarket or well be
not the train here no it was like the
busiest train ever but the sickness was
empty
that's how it is often if you want to
see real family I'm sorry I can't take
any chances
I've never felt uncomfortable there's no
no which is rare right because you live
in you don't live in Tokyo I don't live
in take a live in North Japan and I've
traveled Japan extensively like so much
and I very honestly can't think of an
experience where someone has been openly
racist towards me or maybe feel
uncomfortable but I've kept an eye out
for it make no mistake people expect and
those bars where foreigners aren't
welcome a few and far between and
they're often right in tourist areas
where there's a bar that has regular
customers and they probably just don't
want foreign customers coming in because
they can't communicate in that respect
hitting on that point I watched a video
of yours again last night yeah I went I
was in a deep dive I did I did in in
2018 of October hahaha
you over the video where you are how
long will I live in Japan for yeah in
that video you were like maybe like
another three years we're getting close
to that point Chris and I was wondering
like what are your thoughts about that
now yeah or is this gonna be something
discussed in a video you know there's no
again there's still no plans to be
honest like before I leave the one thing
I always want to do is to film a short
film to make a film well everything I've
been doing all these years been building
up to that moment in my free time I've
been studying cinematography and stuff
and that is the one thing I want to do
so I feel like once I've done that maybe
alright well if you did ever leave Japan
how do you think like your channel right
cause it's abroad in the UK
you almost feel the times it like maybe
you're like not not say like hostage did
you can but kind of like you're like
well my job is Japan like can I leave
subjects not really how do you think so
but not necessarily no yeah I mean my
channel is let's face it the reason the
channel so success was because most of
my viewers are interested in a pan right
right and I'm fine with that I do have a
second channel called a broad
perspective right right you upload a lot
of videos where you just just chat [ __ ]
to the comments that you get right it's
fantastic absolutely how about charisma
oh there are applying to hate comments
video comments where you a lot of videos
where you just you know reply to
comments and those get just as many of
you sometimes as your ad so I feel like
you know even if you did leave you could
easily transition was it yeah I mean I
do think if I had to leave Japan god
forbid there would be a future I would
be able to do something out of pivot and
create a channel that's focused on
comedy or commentating or something but
really I've always seen my youtube
channel as a YouTube channel and also a
stepping stone as stepping stone to
getting into the film industry and the
price in the world of film so is that
like your alternate goal after you those
multiple go and 2020 was supposed to be
or supposed to be the year that I did
that wow that's kind of in a bit delayed
slowly so you so you have like no
interest in like staying for the
foreseeable future I think I'll be here
at least another three years I don't
have a like it's time to go now and go
like I have to leave your pan like
realistically you know okay and I'll
come but could you see yourself like if
you did stay in Japan like eventually
like you've done so much content in and
around Japan could you ever see yourself
at a point where it's like I've
literally run out of every idea that I
can think of that's like interesting
enough in Japan because you know like as
you think so it's diverse and as like
interesting as all sorts of places in
Japan are if you cover also all the
interesting stuff eventually you'd think
you're gonna run out right so like could
you ever see yourself like getting to
that point or what I'd probably fail
before that happens it's a good question
there are people asked that a lot like
are you fed up of covering Japan
and I think it's always a new angle news
story to be found like recently I've
been working on a series about business
owners in Japan so I made a series about
a guy that owns a sushi restaurant and
what's it like and he's a good friend of
mine in Sendai he owns the biggest sushi
restaurant chain and I've got another
friend who owns a Wagyu restaurant with
him are we gonna make a video on that so
focusing on people is another option
right I've never really done that and to
do so focusing on different people so I
always think there's another angle
there's another story to be told I don't
think you know I've got 20 30 40 ideas
the back of my mind all written down a
document I can go yeah because there's
no absence of content yeah because I
feel like as a youtuber especially if
you're on the platform for like a very
long time you eventually have to think
about evolving your content right right
because like anyone like if you pay
attention to the world of YouTube anyone
who's successful in here or has been for
a very long time their content has to
like slowly change over time where you
have to try to explore new things and I
feel like one of the biggest challenges
is trying to figure out what you can
kind of get away with right because what
what what what what what I fear most is
getting pigeon holed into like one type
of content I love anime right but like
have you ever felt like you wanted to
make content outside of anime or like
something that's not about Japan itself
I mean that's like like specifically
bowing anime because I do have so many
other like interesting like things that
I do I I have like I love anime don't
get me wrong polite I also like a lot of
other things and unfortunately I can't
really talk about that kind of stuff
without it being very unnatural love I
mean I like what you have meaning of
life you know I'm like like before anime
like I was I was in likes like four
different bands are you making yeah
music I make a lot of music like the
sideline so like I've always been very
passionate about music I've always
wanted to like talk about music and I
did that a little bit on my second
channel but and obviously didn't really
pop off hold on my mom's making a
channel Joey's song
music if you like I had a bunch of my
audience which is like if you ever like
start talking about music it's just
called The Music Man and I was that
close to making a channel called the
music I'm like one the API is gonna be
the one you'll be the man and then
something in between yeah exactly
no one there's a one in there somewhere
yeah I mean you have to bear in mind I
was literally doing like Sebastian my
whole channel wasn't personally yeah
honestly surprised you - escaped that
pigeon or I don't know how I did it I
took so many tries I remember so many
videos that I did one that wasn't that
fail but also ya know I I know this is
good yeah gonna make it work then like
what like five years later I'm making
host club videos they're pulling way out
you know like yeah yeah yeah persistent
and it's hard because you're gonna get
discouraged no it isn't normal used to
yeah people don't like what you know
they they uncomfortable with and Athiya
is if you am sure you guys will happen
so you've asked your viewers for
suggestions that never one they give you
this they like do the same thing again
but slightly different and it's just
like alright well you cleave don't know
what you want yeah exactly they don't
know what they want a lot of the times
yeah and you just have to be like I I
like you said right you found a story
you found the people to talk yeah you're
like maybe people wouldn't click on you
know when you started why would someone
click on that ski the documentary right
exactly
but you've built it up to the point
where okay people trust you and they
understand that you you go into that I
think that's the end game with any
successful YouTube channel is to build
it around your personality yeah yeah I
spent years getting out of yeah and I
think you've done an amazing job of
doing that I mean I watched not ski
documentary and I don't know like if
you'd have pitched that to me before I
watched your channel I'd have been like
yeah no I'm okay
very good stanza
but yeah I mean it's it's that kind of
evolution that you really like strive
for right that you can hope you can make
an hour documentary on your mate you're
just [ __ ] around and you're alright
that's it's like and that's it I think
that's a like a testament to how well
you've built your you and your brand
right and that's the I mean that yeah
that's the end game you want to got it
run yourself you want to build it around
your friends you know yeah and find the
right people to put in front of the
camera like a ski exactly you know you
can tell you're careful with it like I
feel like you're not just like I mean
I'm sure if there's people around you
and you happen to film you put them on
but it it seems very like selective the
way you who you show and how you show
them on screen I don't know if you think
about that much but you for you for you
are you very like selective about what
you show I have to in that ski it was
Japan off the cycle where all the guests
came to one room in Shibuya Jay was like
oh it's jelly and he thought Joey's name
was genuinely jelly seen doctor jelly
and just thought oh maybe because he
didn't understand it was a pun because
of the jelly and there are jelly yeah
that's the new podcasting name for Joe
is now to keep genuine like a really
good mate in real life you guys hold
that comes off that way I've been
shocked if you like now he's genuine
relationships it's been really fun as
well taking that skill on for the ride
as a guy that lives randomly in this
kind of backwater of Japan that no one
knows about and then he thrust into the
global just thrust into the world of
internet with millions of years it's
kind of been quite interesting living
vicariously through his experience I
feel like we've all done a pretty good
job in life building our own personal
brands I mean I'm sure if we look at our
content like five years ago it's
completely different
I mean the fact that we can make a
podcast like this and yeah well happy to
tune in when they are completely
different to our normal stuff I'm saying
I mean I remember when I stopped having
to do like anime reviews I know it was
like a conscious choice there's there
was a point when I just I I kind of
realized that anime reviews just didn't
really have a future on YouTube like
remember the back in a day where at like
anime content was just reviewing anime
shows and you needed to give it a score
oh you like that remember right yeah but
like it was really scary just to like
have to like stop doing that because
when you do new content and all your
audience is like why aren't you doing
this kind of old content anymore you
kind of like you kind of just have to
trust yourself that you know the best
direction for your channel even if a lot
of your audience is like yeah I kind of
got blessed in that aspect because I
came into the YouTube world when the
reviewing scene was slowly dying because
like when you were around back in late
before 2010 yeah that was anime
contantly all of anime content was like
if you're not making a review on a
certain show yes this is like what I
said oh yeah right it's like people just
don't think outside the box right yeah
yeah yeah and they think that's what I
can do because like I would watch those
like kinds of reviews and I'm like I
could very much do that but I knew that
like I wasn't gonna be as good as like
yeah like some other like oh geez in the
community so I'm like okay I've got to
come in with like a different twist yeah
and I think in terms of like my
inspirations for like my oldie content I
definitely took inspiration from like
just general vloggers like Ryan Higa all
like you know Smosh back in the day
we're just like [ __ ] turn on the
camera and oh just talk about whatever
the [ __ ] was on their mind yeah and like
I don't know like because like my first
video was it wasn't even an anime review
we right now it was just like I was
[ __ ] complaining about the dub of
samurai champloo my [ __ ] that was my
first review so I really came out the
gate with like the most controversial
[ __ ] yeah what do you mean I'm into that
but in this video but in that video I
trashed it because I was like no i
didn't like dog whatsoever but like i
think Chris knows Chris hahaha
like bottom line it's like I would look
at these anime reviews and I really
enjoyed them because I was like I would
genuinely get like good ready guys watch
each other back then yes I know
so they were like no I don't want yeah
okay with this this actually transitions
nicely to the next question then next
topic I think we can talk about which is
so I took two years off YouTube right
yeah I worked at the BBC Oh tell me
about Gunn we talked we talked about
like years ago what did I say oh but no
like yeah I hey because I I had the
point when I needed to make the decision
okay cuz I I did YouTube when I was 17
and then I did it throughout uni
basically graduated and I was like okay
do I pursue this as a job or do I do I
do I do a normal job and do of
nine-to-five job and I remember when I
finished uni like it was unheard of to
basically make money off anime content
you know what I mean anime was like I
was at the top of basically you'd like
the antecube sphere at that point and I
had like barely a hundred thousand
subscribers and like I wasn't monetized
yeah yeah yeah this was this was like
2011
no because monetization a back then was
like a really right yeah it was it was
like a really new thing and me being a
nanny tuber like who the [ __ ] gets
monetize on foot on YouTube for anime
right so it was like I had basically no
revenue streams that I could basically
point to because I saw you know vloggers
and other people making money but I was
like like I have nowhere near the
numbers that are that are capable of
make generating income so I made the
conscious decision to like just quit
YouTube and do do a full-time job and in
that time Jerry rose up so quickly
passed it's so quickly and and I'm like
holy what the [ __ ] he's getting over
like 500k viewers
what subscribers what is this what is
this whoa
it's a swanky hair I know he's new he
promote proteins for protein
jelly and basically it was in that two
years or like two and a half years that
I was gone that I I've already saw an
audience in the anime sphere that I
never had seen before and I was like
holy [ __ ] maybe maybe I could make
something on this and I remember it was
Sydney that actually convinced me to be
like God just shut up you'll be talking
about for too [ __ ] long quit your job
and just do you to Burke and I was like
fine I'll like I'll give it a go but a
good job at the BBC to doing anime
that's quite a big leap right yeah if
you aren't in that position with a job
and then they move I mean do your job at
the BBC no I was going to quit either
way so the reasoning was I was like
looking for a new job anyway so I was
like this is the perfect chance to do
something risky with my life and
basically because I had this thing on
YouTube ages ago like I didn't even know
if anyone still watched me or whatever
so it was nerve-wracking coming back to
YouTube right because I went to the you
know like I said like the top of the you
the Annie choo game which wasn't really
that big looking back but it was it was
still like gone from that to almost
completely irrelevant so I didn't know
if anyone still remembered me or
anything like that two years is a long
[ __ ] time in YouTube terms and so it
was so [ __ ] nerve-wracking having to
choose to come back to YouTube I
remember the conversation my parents
when I said I'm gonna quit the BBC and
do YouTube to talk about anime they were
not happy they were not happy at all
they they tried everything to convince
me to like okay you want to quit the BBC
that's fine we understand just just just
find another job
Grieg on and basically the only way I
was able to convince them was I had like
I made the decision like half a year
before so I had saved up all this money
in that time I done nothing then didn't
really go out or do anything I just put
it all into my savings and like look
I've call this money my savings just let
me do this for half a year if it doesn't
work out I will quit YouTube straight
away remember the video when you came
back because we're like pretty big news
in the energy world works like Giga
who's like like super Oh genie anjikuni
everybody knows who he is even with the
two-year break he's coming back
right like when that happened and your
video you were you were like I'm gonna
do YouTube for a year and if it doesn't
work out during that time I'm
disappearing you don't want in the
disappear let's giving this attention in
turn off now you're a great mate all of
them if you don't directly direct
deposit to this account
cuz like the biggest thing that made me
can that allowed me to come back to
YouTube was patreon did you guys
experienced the same thing where when
patreon first launched it was like if
you if you had a page show and you're
like the devil like I can't believe you
are trying to make money off youtube is
so long to launch a patreon yeah I had
the idea in 2015 but I didn't do it till
2016 yeah and and now it's become an
accepted thing and I you know I paid a
bronze pan has it pays a heavy debt to
patreon and the folks that support the
channel
yeah so yeah yeah it's enabled me to not
just think I need to put out videos
every day I need to like I can actually
think great yeah I have to put
Squarespace in every video what audible
I can do and those down and focus on
doing what I enjoy doing
yeah yeah because like I it's it would
be impossible for so many people to do
what they do including me when I started
without patreon and it just it just
changed the game so much in terms of
people who could do YouTube for a job
which is please let me on to my next
question is like when did you guys
realize or made the decision to be like
this is gonna be my job this is the guy
gonna be my livelihood
for me when I was teaching English I did
YouTube as a side hobby right right and
about the second year I had about 20,000
subscribers which is a lot of people but
I said to myself like I'll consider
doing it full-time if I hit a hundred
thousand because I think from a hundred
thousand you've got a strong support
base there
build up yeah and so that was the
turning point for me a hundred thousand
right but I didn't make much money from
it and I had to take out a bank loan of
like it's like make or break I took yes
so I had to paid off yes but that worked
because I was able to create content
that create ad revenue from those videos
I built up more subscribers from those
subscribers I was able to launch patreon
after best there was and that's that's
how the channels worked really did did
you get any pushback from any like
family or friends when they when they
found out you're gonna like you know
stay in Japan keep doing YouTube they
pretty supportive and also just they
just don't mind
they just yeah yeah British parents are
kind of just like telling to an Asian
parent after your best son has just gone
through four years of university to get
a masters degree and then get a job at
the BBC they're gonna quit that to talk
about anomie titties like I remember my
dad telling me I can't believe you just
like wasting four years of my life I was
because I was doing I was my third year
of uni I [ __ ] hated it
and I was really like I didn't do it but
it was because I at that point I had
really found like voiceover and I found
a bit of house dabbling in YouTube and I
really felt like first what first time
my life I found something that I enjoyed
doing right and I was terrified to tell
my parents I was like oh my god like
tell because I was gonna do a master's
in engineering yeah but I was like
alright how do you the bachelors in my
head and I'll get out but I was
terrified to tell my parents
cuz me and my brother yeah actually
killed it he was the model son right
when I did engineering did aeronautical
engineering went into an amazing job and
is doing great right perfect British son
right yeah the track and I was like come
on just [ __ ] around in London and make
video do some commercials not a fan and
to pursue that sport they were like okay
we'll see I guess the pressure that
comes with like not being the firstborn
right yeah I mean yeah
III think my parents said they haven't
said this but they were like if he [ __ ]
up he'll deal with it right yeah we'll
help him out right but if you know we'll
let him do well under [ __ ] around he's
yeah my family didn't even believe I was
moving to Japan I'm going to get the
Virgin Atlantic flight now Japan oh yeah
do you when you moved to Japan I was new
20
oh okay it's just after university is a
major yeah they were just like what
about you Joey cuz I mean you're you are
doing YouTube videos throughout
university as well I mean I started in
my first year at uni and then thank God
in my third year of uni I went from like
50k to like half a mil I was like [ __ ]
you money too much yeah yeah my god that
must have been the best uni experience I
could ever think over getting like 400
pounds of a dress on and I was like yeah
guys I'm gonna buy this right no I was
like cuz you know take one Pam shots
right yeah five shots really cuz in uni
it's like it's like 30 quid for an eye I
was like yeah that's a price isn't it
yeah like my loan is not gonna pay for
this what the [ __ ] you getting your
money from I mean I mean at least for me
like it wasn't so much like the aspect
of like oh do you have enough money or
it's more like you know because I have
family here and I've spent like half my
life here my parents knew just from how
much I loved and respected Japanese
culture and the language that I was
going to move here eventually and I was
like if I if you should never like went
off of me I was gonna move here and do
something kind of
[ __ ] IT job here oh yeah because I
even like I even intern at a at an IT
job here when I had like 30 thousand
subs or something yes so like and and
during that intern as well every day I
would like just be like oh do you want
to go out for a drink intern and I'm
like no thanks I got to record a YouTube
video do that like I would go back to my
cousin's place I was staying at my
cousin's place at the time and I would
[ __ ] come back and [ __ ] record a
YouTube video yeah because I knew that
like if I kept going with this [ __ ] it
was eventually gonna lead somewhere sure
yeah and thank god it did so by the time
I graduated uni my parents in year like
it wasn't a secret right my parents that
I wasn't doing YouTube and they were
like you know silently following me on
my whole YouTube thing so they saw like
how much I blow up in my blaster beauty
where when I said to them hey I'm
thinking he moved to Japan to be YouTube
oh my parents is just like yeah I mean
it seems like you're making enough money
than [ __ ] yeah and like I made a
promise to my mom she's like cuz typical
Asian parent she's like okay I see
you're being super successful and you're
probably making more money than most uni
graduates right now I'll make you a deal
if you're able to continue this by the
time you're 24 years old then I'll let
you do it for for the foreseeable future
but it's not you do drag you but if not
you have to go and get a real job at the
age 24 now still though in a baby
because the biggest thing I had to like
explain to my parents all but the
biggest thing my parents were worried
about was like the concept of being a
youtuber as a career as opposed to be
like okay you're making money you know
you can keep it but like when when I
quit my job I was like uh how old was
like [ __ ] I was like 25ish 20 can't
remember exactly when I came back some
I'm sure someone in the YouTube comments
were no but they were it was like you
know I was in like made my mid-twenties
and like the concept of quitting my
career job to do a YouTube thing Nev
like even if I was making money was just
so alien and even to me like I didn't
even know if I if YouTube could be a
career that could do four years down the
line like has that been ever like a
worry for you guys like how long you can
basically do this for I thought
thought to myself because it's really
hard with Yugi right because as of right
now
there is no previous example of someone
being able to do this for like 50 years
right it's not like it's not like every
other industry industry like the movie
industry or the music industry where
there are examples of people who have
been able to do it their entire career
from like the 2670 yeah yeah because
YouTube is like one not even 15 years
old at this point we don't know if it's
gonna be the next TV or if it's just a
fad Yeah right
get ready for tick tock honestly so like
it that's what's like the scariest thing
about them I think that's why I've
slowly come to the realization they're
like I can't put all my eggs into the
YouTube basket yes
you really don't know if it's one day is
just gonna [ __ ] disappear yeah that's
my backup know why backup right yeah
it's just like thought about it I
believe that it'll be all right yeah yes
you will be okay YouTube we talked about
the turmoil of YouTube how it is but at
the end she was fairly stable and it is
fairly ok yeah it's all sustainable that
I think youtubers like to make up it is
it is we like to play devil's advocate
defamation I've got a podcast I do as
well occasionally I do sponsor stuff got
patreon so I have lots of different yeah
if YouTube falls then hopefully I can
bounce back something oh yeah yeah make
my transition to the film mystery but
that's why I do have my i aways on the
future yeah the film moving to TV doing
something like that yeah the day really
YouTube will always be for the
foreseeable future hopefully 10 years
that's my main bread and butter that's
why I think that's why I enjoy doing the
way I see it as far as like you know
it's not often you had an opportunity
like this in like your life yeah yeah
yeah even if it did fall through so
[ __ ] what I had a good time yeah
yeah if you even if you were like a
millionaire if you were worth 500
million dollars Connor you probably
still do what you do yeah yeah it's what
I love to do you don't do it for the
money you do because you actually enjoy
commentary you enjoy the I love the
creative aspect like I went through four
years of engineering to realize I don't
want to do engineering do three years of
engineering to realize thank you
I remember I was distinctly out of this
I was in my dissertation my final
dissertation and I did some Electrical
Engineering for it and I was like figure
out like Electrical Engineering special
boy studies no I did business and
English linguistics
I felt I feel like that is a litmus test
right if you had like a billion dollars
right yeah you still probably want to do
what you do now yeah that's the main
test if you enjoy it or not I've always
wanted to and I think the other boys can
detest to this but like I've always
wanted to ask you and I'm pretty sure I
asked you personally about how you got
to do your tip or do you oh I could
believe guys I [ __ ] love TED talk is
it as a meme yeah so yeah we really
wanted to know which what we want to
know how you got that how that
opportunity came up and like just just
walks through the whole process TED talk
about being a huge achievement in North
Japan and talking about what it's like
there's a big toe Hawker University
which is one of the top three
universities in Japan actually and they
were like do I do a TED talk on how
YouTube can be used as a way of
encouraging people to come and talk
right but I was quite nervous at public
speaking because doing this where it's
three four drunkards in a room just
two thousand people going excellent no
absolutely it's because like there's no
feedback you're just talking to a camera
you know I'm not making a fool of myself
in front of people I think I'm too
British yeah I want to I want to do a
tattoo like and ironically said like I
would love to do it what about about it
like dr. jelly do honestly if someone
was like you do it tape talk about white
animes or something like [ __ ] yeah
exactly
let's go he's something of passion about
how YouTube is a great tool for
promoting North Japan I had lost
something given I'd done it for five
years of that I mean yeah I mean I saw
the video and you seemed like quite
natural yeah yeah is the last [ __ ]
Speaker of the day and I was like as I
said I'm nervous doing probably speaking
yeah yeah yeah this is the biggest
speech I've ever done in front of a
crowd
2,000 people or something everyone's
talking and I'm the last one I'm just
sitting there like shake and then you go
up and you know I I need to act cool
what I'm like yes and there's like a
timer before you O king timer
oh god 15 minutes go like was there part
of you really should have timed this to
one minute and I went I went ten seconds
over Oh I remember watching loads
I watched Ken Robinson which is a really
good TED talk he talked about how
schools kill creativity it's when the
best speeches on Ted and one the biggest
most viewed it's a great speech I just
thought I'll just do that
20 times I'll just walk him across stage
deliver lines like this in intonation
and I just I remember I comment like
mimicking his intonation I just did not
care Robinson and it what did you did
you do like a lot of prep I
scripted the speech and then in my
apartment the day before I let you sit
really go I just did it once twice like
a tally chart five times across six
times and that's all there is to it huh
yeah it wasn't too bad because obviously
you can just wing it
you
I did a Japanese speech contest once and
in that was extremely difficult a police
and you're not allowed to deviate from
your own script because the judges have
a script script in front of you like
perfect and so I done that and that was
obscenely complicated it's the process
of that like how did you get that like
how did you get into that and then I do
some like one paragraph a day he was he
read my homies a 50-minute speech
delivered entirely Japanese I really
English translated it and affected it
and then I just broke it down to
paragraphs
rised memorization technique to get
through it at that point how good was
your Japanese speaking I guess a
conversationalist in conversation okay
yeah and they gave me four does another
speech contest and I just forgot it I
got like three
yeah I'm like a parasite bombs had to
read off a sheet and learn from that
experience it [ __ ] speech I'm gonna
do it it works really well but so doing
that really prepared me for the TED talk
and after that TED talk I was like okay
I don't feel that nervous about public
speaking anymore now if you got the
offer sorry what'd you do another TED
talk awesome Japan is yeah value of
strong need strong Oh cuz that sounds
like my worst nightmare I hate public
speaking and I've only gotten better
about it because I've you know done
panels and like it's it's like a fight
fight or flight' kind of situation right
once you've done it a few times you do
learn to enjoy it yeah yeah I mean we
just dragged him out recently to do a
video shooting in public that was that
was all it's not out yeah it's actually
gonna be you know like it's all by the
time of this recording obviously we went
around Akihabara and buying as much
stuff as we cured for finally a box yeah
yeah this is all there's the challenge
and we had a bunch of challenges and now
he'd never done any video or anything
like that before and it was really fun
seeing him
something slightly how you get like
spied in public while you're filming
yeah I mean we we had we got permission
to film where we did though there was
still like people there but I think the
biggest thing for me is that I'm just
like my videos halves are scripted
they're like perfectly planned perfectly
like I know everything that's gonna yeah
so like when you just stick a camera in
front of me and just expect me to just
talk and like the podcast is different
because I got you guys it's like I I
need that conversation I need I need
that bounce back because if it's just if
it's just a camera and I'm like I'm kind
of I kind of speak and I almost like
instinctively wait for a response and
then I realized that no response is
coming so I start panicking so I'm like
oh oh [ __ ] arm did but did I make the
point I was I wanted to make and it's
it's like the first time I tried filming
the intro for this video I I was just
like panicking people are looking at you
yeah yeah I just wasn't used to it but
no cuz I remember my first panel and I
was equally as nervous for my very first
panel and there was it was it was like
back then I was only laughs like in
front of like 50 people anime convention
I haven't I got invited to a few I felt
like I was misplaced because I were in
yeah you'd be good on the panel light
like calm down
Japan stuff yeah yeah I mean like if
you're talking about something you know
about you're passionate about it's it's
easy because my experience of public
speaking had come from school right my
god like doing doing presentations in
university that's actually worth
something for your final grade it's just
like [ __ ] awful I gave the [ __ ]
worst speech for my dissertation my
dissertation failed completely I'd built
these renewable energy devices that just
did not [ __ ] work and they were so
poorly made and I had to like it's like
selling a product that you know doesn't
work and I knew was it like two minutes
of this like 10 minute speech that my
professors they they knew it was [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I have to keep selling it like
but it's very renewable you see
and when the water comes up the magnet
will power the let us litter explain
like basic like physics to them and it
should have been like way more in-depth
and somehow they gave me a good grade I
think as I was hopefully at least
somewhat charming yeah I think I was
like I was just like playing it off and
I'm like well I guess it's just I
remember I was like it should work but
it just doesn't make it laughing and I'm
like alright well I think the joke saved
me I wasn't [ __ ] all for ya cuz like
I remember like okay here's his thing
like I remember back in back in my
university days I I had kept my the fact
that I was a youtuber or did YouTube
videos completely secret oh yes a shame
because my roommates found out
immediately when they heard me [ __ ]
making anime screaming because like any
time I would record my my housemates to
be like oh we practicing for a
presentation and I was like yeah I was a
practicing for presentation they
believed that they believed that I
remember doing like moaning for like a
character and I came out my room they
were all just outside looking at me I
was like I see because when I was at uni
I was like attending uni from home like
from my parents place so like I had the
privacy yeah yeah yeah so I have to
travel like two hours one way to like go
to uni every day and then two hours to
come back and so like I was like the
only people who heard me was my sister
and my parents and I was questioned
[Music]
that's all that's all you man still
stuck true to myself I always unlucky
because obviously I was a teacher and in
my second year my channel he took off
for my I don't know how my students
found out about me but they did and so
every time I went from being Christine
said
that's kind of awkward weird you should
be acting like it's a broad in japan koi
an awkward situation 12-under student
shall we isn't it so strange now how
we've gone from that to like at least in
Japan all these young kids wanting to
come
yeah yeah right like if you ask kids
nowadays they tend to say they won't be
you choose my boy why I mean I get it
but at the same time it's like it's it's
very stressful times I feel like if
you're not like mentally like strong
enough it can really break you know but
for me like compared to getting 100k
getting a million just for some reason
didn't feel as good I just felt like it
ticked over you know yeah yeah it's like
when like your car hit like a hundred
thousand miles like yeah and it's just
like I feel like mental health I'm just
taking care of your mental this like
such an important thing to to to think
about when you're becoming a youtuber
nobody really thinks about that when
they say oh yeah want to be a youtuber
life you've certainly gonna grow a thick
skin I mean I do read most of my
comments to my videos I feel like no
same I make a video it's like hosting a
party and you want to be there for the
party you don't just make you video then
[ __ ] off you know be there for house by
mingle with the guests and then go to
sleep at 4 a.m. and I love that and I
love that but if you do read the
comments they'll always be the ones that
like oh you're fat now someone call it
said you look like a [ __ ] Elon Musk
it's the ones where they do like just
the littlest job yeah it gets you yeah
yeah well they might have said saying
that that one thing in the video you
were insecure about yeah it just ruins
you you're like [ __ ] my whole day is
ruined because of that one comment I
mean I got my fair share of that when I
was on you journey across Japan well I
think you always get it when as a new
person on the channel a few gets got
that wasn't just you Jen across Japan
Joey like my good friend Pete you know I
do the pod care
he got that as well yes new guest is
very different right well you've always
gonna get that I think I mean how did
you guys deal with hate comments or like
a youtuber what a normal person would
consider hate and what a youtuber can
see you have to really push that that
goal to like like yeah if you if you
consider even the slightest thing hey
you can yeah that's like it's like it
depends like it depends on what they say
right when it's something like very like
opinionated like I just don't like
so-and-so because I just don't yeah it's
like you can't really do anything about
it because that's just their opinion
yeah yeah when it's like really
persistent and really petty that's when
you'll like okay like what what's your
issue like some of those funny it's like
I said I said the ones where they just
find out one thing you're worried about
that specific thing somehow flagging did
they know what you're insecure about
there's that one thing like you can you
can have like the worst hate comment in
the world and it's like what sometimes
like a one sentence comment just like
bothers you for the entire day like I've
had commented like you're an [ __ ] I'm
like that's funny
yeah just like that I come or what it
was to us I read recently I was like
[ __ ] you you got me better I hate you so
much I was it so what are you my
therapist just hit you in like where you
were like you were insecure about it
yeah but you if you just kind of learn
like alright yeah that sucks but I'm
gonna try if I if I let it affect the
videos then you know yeah that's what I
feel like the craze that phase is over
but hate mail reading comment you know
reading those videos yeah that was
really fun I feel like you can't really
do any more I feel like it happened like
three years ago to that it was yeah yeah
I did one like three years ago videos
rode that wave and viewers always loved
it the comments I used to get ridiculous
like I hate British men that speaks with
the mouth like pit bull just like so
brilliant you won't we put on a team
yeah yeah alright when you pin the the
good comment yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
good insult you like arm up in there
really call me a [ __ ] you are a
[ __ ] because in the UK we have
[ __ ] which are like meatballs
yeah because I feel like your dad's
right you adapt your Lud
yeah I mean it kind of sucks right
because like as anyone like any
influence I gotta hate using that word
oh my gosh II would oh the words I don't
want to be associated with me but still
as they seem to think you know at least
favourite word next to call creator for
like like a lot of questions I get from
like other smaller craters like how
would you do or hate comments how did
you not let that affect you and I think
it [ __ ] sucks that all you can say is
it's got you get used to it and that
that's not that's not a solution that's
the [ __ ] coping mechanism it's you
know what I mean part of the job yeah
yeah yeah do you remember when you start
uploading first and you got that first
dislike and you were like who [ __ ]
did this who dislike this how and then
most yeah now you should accept that for
some reason you'll have a thousand and
you're not really sure why you have
thousand but you're like that's normal
and then you don't but when you think
about it alike when you think about a
thousand people surrounding you who just
[ __ ] dislike yeah oh okay I remember
there would be like I had a friend who
and they started out there like a mental
breakdown when they got a dislike right
they're like who disliked it no one of
the comments that we disliked did write
this why do they do it and it's like
it's like I just got to deal with it ya
know cuz like um I remember one of the
hardest lessons I had to learn was just
learning that you can't please out of
everyone yeah and they're especially
like I remember a point when it seemed
like every everyone everyone was
positive about what you were doing you
know that's what how it is yeah yeah and
then you started you you reach this
point when people would just start
hating you like as a person or mate like
they personally dislike your personality
or something about you and you're like I
don't know why you dislike me I've never
met you I never seen you but you seem to
dislike me and I'm just like having to
learn that there are just gonna be
people that dislike you is
like one of the hardest things I've had
to learn it's still a thing I think I
still like have to like come to terms
with it yeah like you'd like some people
are just gonna dislike you
yeah and it sucks you have to accept
that right I feel especially when like
you know when again like because the
large majority of YouTube is American
and I don't wanna say like Americans
don't get sarcasm but a lot of them
don't and I'm totally all four of us are
very well versed any form of jokes right
at could fall flat and yeah Thanos Mir
amiibo get angry about me swearing oh
yeah really comment I get people like
stop you're ruining Japanese culture by
swearing like yes me speaking words in
ruining an entire culture that's back
there three four thousand years words
can bring down a culture that is
hypocrisy that is [ __ ] stupidity yeah
swearing in the UK so ingrained in my
only do is every video I said con like
two or three times at least and there
would always be that one color which is
like I don't like it when you use the
c-word I'm like yeah like I get because
have you heard Americans say the word
can't it's it's like I like you know
with your maids in England or straighter
you say you say it with a [ __ ] time
like I can't how are you doing yeah but
when you say an American you want to
hear an American say you're like oh like
wash your [ __ ] mouth and please so
elongated in American so like it's the
hardest is the way we we tap you're like
yeah British but in American they the
are is a full sound so I don't know I
was thinking about different thing I've
lost in my mind I don't know I'm going
on about just take care of I'm like yeah
I definitely like I still get comments
would you like I don't like it with you
swearing because my kids are into anime
and I don't want my kids to know
affected by your anime titties all the
time what do you mean yeah it's right
and it's like it's like like let me do
what I want dude like I'm sorry that
your kids you know
like when I say [ __ ] can't but like
I'm sorry that's to me cuz cuz like to
me is a Brit like the word [ __ ] is just
like a filler words sometimes mean like
some songs you're just thinking you're
like what was a [ __ ] saying yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] British and Australian
language is like the equivalent so like
the would really well it's not really
hard it's [ __ ] hard situation we
obviously weren't brought up in a
Christian household swearing but that's
another story for now the time that's
like sweating a safe I'm gonna talk
about it it's not right I know I guess
that's I think that's everything I had
in mind you want to share Chris there's
TV video Chris's channel with a mini
hello it's the video I've told about it
now it's come out already so you should
check it out on the bunch of pan channel
it's been I've not been a room with like
two other British guys in about eight
years versus just a bonus sighting
transcendent experience to come to the
anime Church Wow so we've like prepared
like a how is the Japan style yeah yeah
yeah yeah bar a restaurant a pan they
have these and they'll be honored to
have you sign it we have like this blank
wall yeah yeah why not with every single
guest that comes onto the show we get
them to sign this and so that so after a
special message or whatever it whatever
you like in the meantime thank you to
our wonderful patrons for supporting
this episode yeah name's Ron's Queens
right now if you'd like to support the
show and help us bring in more guests
like Chris or other people then yeah
you'll some patron is greatly
appreciated yes and you know if you
enjoyed having Chris on and you know you
enjoyed having guests on you know leave
leave a comment as well because this is
this is new for us as well this Chris
our first guest you guys have been
talking about this empty microphone
since since the first episode I think
what did you write
he said I love you guys especially jelly
bless jelly god bless you good like I
know we're supposed to end it but can I
just quickly talk about how the first
time a heart is like when someone asks
you to sign something as a youtuber and
like you realize you don't have a
signature as a youtuber so like dip I'm
a doctor signature Mycenae said that I
use now was the first time I ever signed
something and I was like [ __ ] it I'll go
with that and I'm with that for like the
past four years but like my signature as
Giga is looks better than my actual
signature like my my actual real name
signature is like [ __ ] squiggles but
there was this one time when like
someone asked me to sign something out
of handle and I just signed it and he
was like you gotta sign it again I can't
really read this Mel's like oh see but
it was it was the pens for me what is
that supposed to be a sea thank you
thank you very much Chris
jelly yes oh we hope you enjoyed this
episode of trash taste
I've been Giga and me has been my
co-host a hentai man c-dawg and Chris
and we will see you guys next time
[Music]